[Music]
[Applause]
she's andrea kramer award-winning
journalist pro football hall of fame
inductee
chief correspondent for the nfl network
and also uh contributes to hbo's real
sports with bryant gumbel also uh a
panelist on cbs sports network we need
to talk she's also going to be part of
the broadcast team with uh hannah storm
that will be cowboys niners coming up
this weekend she also has a podcast oh
come on andrea can you leave a couple of
jobs to somebody else she has a podcast
called nfl films tales from the vault
somehow she's taken time out to talk to
us good morning andrea
hello dan it's such a pleasure and i
would always make time for you you know
that all right even though dan dan yeah
it's not like we had an agreement
but it's just sort of durger that when i
come on the show i have certain
expectations i expect great questions
from you because you are an interviewer
unparalleled but i also expect
a fritzy impersonation and i'm a little
bummed right now
i'm losing my voice here you know
i can hear the emotion in your voice
that uh fritzi is pritzy is not he's
lost his internet connection do you know
he wrote an entire page
for your impersonation he wrote a script
and he never writes anything he had a
script written for his impersonation he
sent that to me early this morning
and i don't know if we can make contact
with fritzy right now okay all i can say
dan is and we love fritzy and you know i
could say that you wouldn't be where you
are today without fritzy but
ability and availability are key right
in any game in any contest yeah uh i
think fritzy is going to try to call in
all right i'll let you know if we make
contact with fritzy all right oh i'm
sure that i'll hear it don't worry um i
just talked to mike florio last hour and
i said if the cowboys don't win this
game i said finish that sentence
and he said he could see where
jerry jones would
try to wrap up kellen moore to make him
sort of a coach in waiting and he may do
that anyway but
the importance of this game
for mike mccarthy is what in your
opinion
this is why they hired mike mccarthy to
win these kind of games
because jerry jones was incredibly
patient with jason garrett
and wanted to bring in an established
coach with a super bowl pedigree super
bowl winning pedigree and that's what he
got in mike mccarthy
and mike mccarthy obviously continued to
let kellen moore call the place so he
could be the coach and really be the
coach of the entire team
and i think that if there is
the most pressure on any individual it
would be mike mccarthy and we know that
kellen moore has already interviewed for
at least one job in jacksonville and
there will be more to come
and uh it would just be interesting dan
to to the point
he was jerry was so patient with jason
garrett will he not be as patient with
mike mccarthy when you look at dallas
and if i say what side of the ball is
going to win this game if they win the
game it will be because of offense or
defense
wow um
i think the fact that you're even asking
that question is showing how balanced
they are
and the fact that they are getting back
uh michael parsons and trayvon diggs who
were among some of the players that were
out last week on the coveted list uh
you know
the niners we know what they're going to
do they're going to run the ball and
they're going to run it hard and they
have proven that they can do that very
successfully
i love to see what micah parsons is
going to do in this matchup because he
is
it's interesting how both teams have
that x factor that positionless player
they've got it in micah parsons on
defense and then of course the niners
have it in demo samuel on offense
and those are some of the key match-ups
that i'm looking for but
i guess
if you really held me to it i'm going to
say what's dallas going to do
defensively yeah
it feels like those two are more
impactful than anybody on the offensive
side of the ball like dak is a good
quarterback uh i'm not a zeke elliott
fan the wide receiver is kind of hit or
miss they have that you know potential
but it feels like diggs and micah
parsons have to make plays in this game
against san francisco but you know the
jimmy garoppolo storyline is really
fascinating though andrew when you think
about he's a lame duck he admitted that
you know it kind of weighed on him this
year
is there any chance that they don't move
on from jimmy garoppolo after this
season do you get any any sense
well i must tell you dan i'm speaking to
john lynch later today and i i think i
would be more informed after i speak to
him later but the reality is is that
the way that garoppolo has handled
things okay and and
let's give kyle shanahan a lot of credit
as well because how many people how many
of your listeners for example would have
thought that down 17-3 at the half with
a guy with a bum thumb on his throwing
hand who is not having
you know relatively little success
moving the ball
and shanahan stayed with him so is that
a reflection on how he felt about trey
lance in that moment or in that in that
at that part of the game or just the
confidence that he had in jimmy
garoppolo look
when garoppolo is half is healthy and
that is always the caveat with anyone
not just todd fritz but also jimmy
garoppolo you know when when someone is
healthy then when garoppolo's healthy he
is a he is a good good quarterback but
again that's the whole reason they made
the move for trey lance is they couldn't
count on him and i think it's really i
think it's it's very very interesting
i'm agreeing with you i think it's a
great storyline what garoppolo has done
not just physically in the way that he's
able to
end up getting the ball down field to to
debo and to to juwan jennings but also
just you know to be able to handle that
kind of stress that kind of pressure uh
look great kiddo uh excuse me um uh
kiddo came to him
george kell came to him before the game
last week and said like is this going to
be our last game together there is a
there's definitely a feeling on the team
of course that this could be it and uh
garoppolo is doing his best to manage it
as best as possible not that john lynch
would answer it but if you said
if we redrafted
john
are you still taking trey lance
or how close were you to actually taking
mac jones
like i i'm just curious because i
trey lance is not ready
he's got a lot of talent he's not ready
um
but mac jones
i mean he's contributing
so
look look the the the anomaly has been
drafting patrick mahomes sitting him for
the entire year behind alex smith
letting him play in a meaningless game
in week 17 and then oh by the way
and then trading away alex smith and
look what patrick mahomes turns into
i think that was the plan i think that
was clearly the plan for the niners that
now again did they have to move up and
give up all those first-round draft
picks to get trey lands that's a whole
other issue but the idea of
if garoppolo's healthy
again always the big caveat if he's
healthy let treyland sit behind him let
him learn maybe get him in a little bit
you know look at remember in the
beginning of the season kyle shanahan
was thinking of platooning them at times
that lasted about two games and that was
gone so that wasn't going to happen but
i think that the idea that that
garoppolo ended up missing two games you
saw i think i don't know 178 or so snaps
from from trey lamps this season but
certainly enough to prove that he as you
point out is not ready to take over the
helm of this team especially in the
playoffs
but again
the fact that they did it that way maybe
with that in mind is i think what uh
what the plan was talking to andrea
kramer she'll be on the call on amazon
prime with uh hannah storm she'll have
the niners and the cowboys
now the worst weather you ever
encountered as a as a sideline reporter
was where well
well um
the worst there was two back-to-back
games there was the 1997 uh divisional
playoff and then nfc championship game
in no surprise green bay
the divisional playoff
against the
niners it was that driving rain that
kind of goes sideways where you have you
have no idea and and the best part of
this is
you of course know stephanie droolie who
uh is now one of the highest ranking
executives at espn she was my producer
at that time
she was forcing me to stand outside and
i'm like don't you realize i'm going to
look so stupid nobody will be paying
attention to what i'm saying they will
be looking at this round rat out here
and of course boomer throw you know
berman throws to me like well andrea's
standing out in the rain to this day
stephanie and i joke about this but the
next week
it was about 34 below wind chill for the
for the conference championship against
carolina and those two games were were
just unbelievable my cameraman took me
to fleet and farm in green bay to make
sure that i had new boots so that i
would not encounter frostbite standing
there
have you ever been wiped out on the
sidelines by player um
oh my god uh
sunday night football
vikings
and i had a wonderful man
named charlie brown
and he would carry the light kit
so i uh i'm standing there on the
sidelines i can't make this up it's kind
of embarrassing but for people who may
not know
i'm 5'2 and i'm barely 100 pounds
adrian peterson
is coming my way and i'm on the
sidelines and i stand up and i put my
arm out like this
and charlie reaches under my armpits and
literally lifts me like a little dog and
he goes
what were you doing and i go
forearm shiver
you know so that's the closest i ever
came to being completely run over and
then i got hit by a ball one time
um
uh which is is not the greatest thing it
was actually pre-game and with a field
goal attempt and i was talking to a
coach and committed the cardinal sin
which is wasn't paying attention and
there you go
you know yeah uh
fritzi is here uh andrea kramer
fritzi uh andrea said that she comes on
the show and she expects you to do your
andrea kramer impersonation i know you
wrote a script for this
okay oh of course you don't all right so
here you don't want to let your you
don't let me down not about your boss
right you don't want to let dan down
like oh by the way you have a job fits
it fritzy
you first dance second that's how it
works okay
all right so give andrea cramer your
best andrea kramer impersonation
thank you dan two hall of fame
quarterbacks who brought super bowl to
the city of denver now find themselves
on opposite sides of the mile high fence
john elway and peyton manning are part
of separate investment groups looking to
buy the broncos seven has the drive but
will he have the necessary money
or will the other nfl owners exclaim
omaha omaha and prefer number 18.
two legends vying for a team who
currently have zero quarterbacks on a
team that hasn't reached the playoffs
since beating the panthers six years ago
in super bowl 50. they lost double-digit
games yet again and have now lost to
their division rival chiefs 13 straight
times one of these two legends will be
orange crushed to learn that their bid
fell short reporting from eagle wood
colorado with the broncos andrew kramer
espn
he said
he couldn't send any script and as long
as he nailed the clothes that's all that
matters yes
see thank you for all the time that you
put into that script
well we we love you i love you and
you're welcome i enjoyed that and uh
you're a good sport
thank you thank you and dan i have to
ask you a question how many years have
you been out of espn
i think uh 14 coming up on 15 years okay
so i'm coming up on 16. i still get
at an airport oh you're my favorite
person on espn to this day
and jimmy roberts told me who left
before me to go to nbc he said that's
going to happen there's just that great
and of course you never have the you
never have the the wherewithal to say i
haven't been there in 15 years but i'm
glad you liked me yeah i have people say
oh i watch on sportscenter every morning
and i go wow that's awesome you know
right and i thought you couldn't tell
anybody no you know no no but you know
it's been 15 years since i did
sportscenter but thank you it's nice
that you uh but you know what you're so
people don't change their viewing
patterns if you think about the number
of channels
that you click to every night there's
probably five channels maybe max that
that you'll stay with and the fact that
sportscenter and espn was just ingrained
in people's daily and nightly routines
i mean it's a testament to the product
that we had but also
you know people want familiarity comfort
but it's also unfortunate because look
you know i did
certainly my share as did you
at espn of the you know exclusive
interviews and back then they meant
something the sunday conversation meant
something and if you wanted to see it
you could only see it on espn
now nobody has any idea really who's
where because everything gets put on the
internet so it's great for distribution
i'm not quite sure about brand
identification but uh but things have
have certainly changed in that way and
and it just it just gets to the glut of
information that's out there
could you do your own sign off here as i
say goodbye to you
wow uh
i wonder who i'm signing off for because
you said i do work for him
how about you can go back how about espn
how about your es no no no no no no no
no no no no no let me write my own
script okay sorry sorry okay all right
let me write let me okay all right my
bad on the top of my head so um
uh i hope that you'll all tune in to
watch hannah storm and i call
cowboys
three three two one i hope you'll all
tune in to watch hannah storm and i
cover cowboys niners wild card super
wild card weekend sunday at 4 40.
reporting for the dan patrick show i'm
uh have fun this weekend great to talk
to you as always
oh it's wonderful to talk to you stay
you stay healthy and everybody that
listens to you and everybody on the
great team stay healthy as well
that's andrea kramer she's in the pro
football hall of fame she also
contributes to
hbo's real sports with bryant gumbel and
uh she'll be part of the broadcast team
with hannah storm that'll be at 4 30
eastern cowboys niners streaming on
amazon prime video